bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce journal
de 20h épilogue dans la sphère din al
materazzi la fifa a tranché trois
matches de suspension pour le jeune
retraité français contre deux pour
l'italien la fédération estime que les
insultes n'avait aucun caractère raciste
le décès du réalisateur gérard oury nous
laisse des comédies de légende la grande
vadrouille ou le corniaud rabbi jacob
des films qui font partie de notre
patrimoine et de notre mémoire
après une journée de léger répit la
canicule va persister sur la moitié est
de la france
vingt-quatre départements sont placés en
vigilance orange jusqu'à dimanche
nous verrons qui sont les gagnants et
les perdants de cette vague de chaleur
malgré les appels de l'onu à un
cessez-le-feu le bras de fer continue
entre israël et le hezbollah
les deux camps semblent s'installer dans
une logique de durée les évacuations
massives d'étrangers se poursuivent de
1500 français ont déjà quitté les bancs
des saisies quasi quotidiennes de corail
par les douaniers d'orly menacé de
disparition le corail est protégé par la
convention de washington son ramassage
et sa commercialisation sont interdits
ouverture aujourd'hui de la 5e édition
de paris-plages nouveauté cette année
les parasols et transats sont aussi
installés rive gauche
une bonne façon d'échapper au 31 degrés
qui écrasait aujourd'hui la capitale et
on commence par le tour de france qui a
renoué aujourd'hui avec les plus grandes
heures de l'histoire de cette
compétition l'américain floyd landis a
fait vibrer les spectateurs après sa
défaillance d'hier plus personne ne
misait sur lui et pourtant il l'a
remporté l'étape de morzine
ce soir il est à 30 secondes à peine du
maillot jaune
le suspense reste entier natale de
rincquesen josé bové ce texte
hier il était à l'agonie aujourd'hui
flot de lundi s'est offert un triomphe
dans les rues de morzine un sacré
retournement de situation en 24 heures
l'américain est revenu dans la course au
maillot jaune
je veux gagner le tour passagers bière
je devais réagir docteur floyd et mr
landis une bonne nuit de repos pour
oublier cette image de l'américain à
l'arrêt dans l'ascension vers la
toussuire 11e au général avec plus de
huit minutes de retard ce matin lundi
décide d'attaquer dès le premier col de
l'étape le maillot jaune hésite mais le
laisse filer une drôle de stratégie
l'américain réalise un festival il
accentue son avance tout au long du
parcours 100 km seul devant le kloto
cinq cols à franchir sous un soleil de
plomb
un exploit il a fait un numéro il a fait
un jour il a gagné l'étape
ces chapeaux mais c'est vrai que c'était
à prendre tu fais ça fait très mal même
oscar pereiro le maillot jaune est à la
traîne
carlos sastre et son dauphin au général
vient de passer à l'attaqué dans la
descente vers morzine le maillot jaune
de pereiro ne tient plus qu'à un fil
l'espagnol doit prendre tous les risques
ça va vite trop vite surtout pour cyril
dessel le français 4e au général
s'accroche aux meilleurs mais chute à 5
km de l'arrivée
ce soir ils rétrogradent à la 7e place
mon boulot d'un plan dommages et j'avais
les vidéos qui marchait plus après donc
je pense que dans l'histoire je perds
une bonne trentaine de secondes périront
peut souffler son maillot jaune est
sauvé mais ça c'était deuxième à 12
secondes
elles disent troisième à 30 secondes le
tour n'a pas été aussi un dc depuis près
de 20 ans l'actualité sportive c'est
aussi les pilotes dans la sphère zidane
materazzi cet après-midi la fifa a donc
tranché trois matches de suspension pour
le front ces jeunes retraités contre
deux pôles italien la fédération a
estimé que les insultes n'avait aucune
connotation raciste karine comme a dit
frédéric de la rue une heure godisson
montres suisses en main a suffi à la
commission pour se faire une idée
mais c'est devant le siège de la fifa
les journalistes venus du monde entier
se contenteront d'une silhouette
derrière une vitre fumée
seuls les fans apprécient important
c'est que les deux qui avait des gens
qui étaient là pour le soutenir et du
soutien zidane en a besoin
le coup de tête est une voie de fait
c'est ce qu'a décidé la commission de
discipline qui condamne le capitaine des
bleus zinedine zidane a été puni
aujourd'hui de trois matches de
suspension et d'une amende de 7500
francs suisses une sanction que dylan et
joueurs retraités mais fidèle à ses
idées a converti en trois jours
d'activités humanitaires avec les
enfants le coupable c'est celui qui
provoque
l'argument de zizou à porter pour avoir
insulté zidane et sa famille materazzi
est condamné à deux matches de
suspension et 3000 euros damende je
compose la provocation parce que c'est
dans le règlement dégénéré à dire pour
les deux journées à m'intéresse mais je
crois que je vais pour france italie en
condamnant les deux joueurs la fifa n'a
réconcilier personnes se supporters de
la juve club a joué zidane a trouvé un
terrain d'entente a aussi joué chez nous
en italie c'est un très bon joueur
le prochain match france-italie aura
lieu au stade de france à paris le 6
septembre la rencontre éliminatoire pour
l'euro 2008 se jouera sans materazzi
mais elle promet d'être sportive
c'est une grande figure du cinéma
français qui vient de nous quitter
gérard oury est décédé chez lui à saint
tropez à l'âge de 87 ans la grande
vadrouille rabbi jacob le corniaud
depuis les années 60 il avait cumulé les
succès commerciaux et s'était imposé
comme le maître de la comédie populaire
mari je jouais
c'est la partition préférée de gérard
oury c'était le rire
sa symphonie la plus jouée la grande
vadrouille devant 17 millions de
spectateurs
c'était il ya quatre ans gérard oury
assister à la projection de son plus
beau succès à l'opéra garnier sur les
lieux mêmes où il avait tourné 40 ans
auparavant c'était pas un rire banal
rire de petite qualité c'était pas un
petit rire franchouillard c'était un
homme très intelligent et très profond
et pourtant le film est venu que vers la
quarantaine
juste après la guerre girard oui s'était
engagé dans une carrière d'acteur des
films noirs comme le miroir à deux faces
cosigne avec andré cayatte maintenant
j'ai réussi dans l'usure que ça sera
effacée comme été gonflé ces deux toiles
vous dis comme ça
la rencontre sur le plateau avec michel
morgant le début d'un grand amour qui
durera jusqu'à la fin de sa vie lassouts
science des années 60 de grands moments
pour gérard oury qui passe derrière la
caméra
les succès s'enchaînent en 1965 le cornu
est amorti en trois semaines la france
découvre un nouveau duo comique deux
acteurs aux antipodes gérard ouvrier a
trouvé une recette qui fera ses preuves
dans la folie des grandeurs ou dans le
cerveau le plus gros budget de l'époque
mais ce qu'il a apporté au cinéma
français n'a pas de prix envie de vivre
envie dry envie de sortir un peu
d'exister à travers des comédies
époustouflante de devis de patcher le
duo comique avec des exceptions pour de
véritable one man show celui de de funès
dans valley jacob ou de belmondo dans
l'as des as
belmont de l'ami encore lui trente ans
plus tard citant un vers de racine quand
gérard vie entre à l'académie des
beaux-arts devenu immortel est un homme
jeune homme avait choisi pour son
dernier film une oeuvre de pagnol
il était une fois dans un petit village
de provence elle nabeul comme épicier
bourrée de complexes et à me dire que je
sois moi rien n'est pas bon à rien mes
mom et âme tout avec 80 environ 80 ans
quand je l'aï rencontré et j'ai vu j'ai
vu un enfant je voudrais ce regard rieur
toujours le mot pour rire faire rire ses
contemporains les rendre heureux leur
faire oublier leurs soucis
c'est comme le dit marcel pagnol c'est
quand même un sacré truc à cesser ses
formes et ça a été peut-être une des
grandes jour de ma vie voilà et la fin
de ce journal on reviendra sur cette
disparition avec un hommage de la rue et
comme chaque soir depuis cinq jours on
évoque cette canicule qui nous concerne
quasiment tous météo france a placé 24
départements en vigilance orange jusqu'à
dimanche soir
vous le voyez il s'agit surtout de la
moitié est de la france
aujourd'hui c'est à lyon qu'il faisait
le plus chaud avec 35 degrés la mort
hier d'un ouvrier sur un chantier à
montrer que la chaleur peut être
mortelle dans certaines conditions de
travail
les autorités appellent donc les
entreprises à la vigilance et certaines
ont dû adapter leurs horaires et leurs
modes de fonctionnement forte chaleur
reportage dans une fonderie à vaulx en
velin dans le rhône stéphanie la brousse
olivier jacque là encore une journée
sous un soleil écrasant
une journée qui n'en reste pas moins de
zones yeuse dans cette petite fonderie
de vaulx en velin et c'est cet ouvrier
qui a ouvert les portes ce matin
bon je viens ici je fais à 3h30 4h du
matin
quand j'ouvre l'atelier il ya 60 degrés
dedans jours et je me sors je sens en
cours en dehors
les températures nocturnes ne permettent
même pas à cet atelier de se rafraîchir
entre deux journées de travail une fois
les machines en route
l'atmosphère se gorgent de chaleur neuf
salariés dont ceux qui s'affairent
autour de creuser ou l'aluminium est
fondu à 720 degrés
au bout d'un moment on sent que nous
mêmes on a du mal à encaisser que on a
nos limites
il ya un moment où il faut on est au
maximum de nos possibilités y faut
savoir s'arrêter un petit veau la
température dans le bureau paraît
presque rafraîchissante
le thermomètre flirte pourtant avec les
34 degrés les pauses se font donc très
fréquentes à 7 litres d'eau par jour et
par personne sont consommés dans cette
salle
actuellement il vient très souvent
surtout en début d'après-midi il passé
sur une norme il passait facilement 25
minutes les horaires de travail ont été
décalés commencé plus tôt pour finir en
tout début d'après midi
pas de climatisation mais quelques
ventilateurs et si la chaleur s'accentue
le responsable envisage un aménagement
supplémentaire à l'extrême en pleurs
richard chômé
ça c'est toujours at on en discute avec
l'équipe
14h37 la journée de ses salariés se
termine une bonne douche du repos avant
d'affronter de nouveau la chaleur dès 6h
du matin
2 le gouvernement continue à afficher sa
vigilance dominique de villepin
président est aujourd'hui un comité
interministériel
chaque jeudi météo france et l'institut
de veille sanitaire ferons un point sur
les températures et les victimes de la
canicule les fabricants de ventilateurs
de climatiseurs ou de fontana au son
comme chaque fois les grands gagnants en
période de canicule
et quand on est commerçant mieux vaut
être équipés pour attirer les clients
séverine lebrun valérie laban un soleil
au zénith et des rues commerçantes
totalement déserté pour séduire le
client tous les moyens sont bons
il ya donc les magasins climatisés comme
celui ci et les autres où personne n'ose
ce risque il rentrait ils sentent qu'ils
sont pas bien haut niveau chaleur et je
pense qu'ils font juste un petit
horizons ont d'autres int en terrasse
c'est pareil il ya celles qui sont
totalement vide
les gens et les serveurs le coin près et
le soleil le midi on a facilement -30%
et les autres qui ont la bonne idée
le brumisateur pour rafraîchir tout le
monde pose en réalité c'est le seul
endroit que nous avons trouvé qu'ils
n'étaient pas au soleil et aux frais
pour de la clim
il faut en moyenne près voire 100 watts
dans ses magasins il y a encore du stock
on peut donc s'acheter une clim mais
après il faut être patient on arrive à
quinze 15 jours trois semaines pour
pouvoir se la faire installer par des
professionnels dans cette entreprise de
fontaines à eau aussi on s'active 50% de
chiffre d'affaires en plus par rapport à
l'année dernière
pas une minute à perdre au quotidien
c'est à peu près entre 50 et 80 appels
jour entre 100 demandes par l'internet
c'est c'est le grand rush effectivement
le soleil en revanche n'est pas l'amie
des bêtes les chansons desséché il faut
déjà nourrir le bétail avec du foie
on entame les stocks d'hiver qui
n'étaient pas déjà sectionnelles quoi la
canicule ne fait donc pas les affaires
de tout le monde il va falloir
s'accrocher car elle pourrait durer
même si cette vague de chaleur n'est pas
comparable avec la canicule de 2003 les
spécialistes s'interrogent sur la
répétition de ces périodes de
températures très élevées
alors y at il un lien avec le
réchauffement de la planète dont on
parle tant éléments de réponse avec
sophie mais elle michel hiver olivier
combe paris et avec elle toute la france
accablé de chaleur les températures qui
dépassent 35 degrés la journée qui se
maintiennent au dessus de 20 degrés la
nuit et ce plusieurs jours durant les
conditions de la canicule sont réunies
le responsable l'anticyclone des açores
qui stagne au dessus de la france ait
agi comme un couvercle qui compresse
l'air et le réchauffe ses épisodes de
plus en plus fréquents sont liés au
réchauffement climatique
on sait que la température moyenne a
augmenté en france d'environ un degré
dans une période d'une centaine d'années
le siècle passé a connu deux très forte
canicule l'été 1947 reste dans les
mémoires de ceux qui faisaient comme ici
la queue à l'entrée des piscines on
suffoque et aussi en 1976 et la canicule
s'est ajoutée une sécheresse
dévastatrice
c'était encore aujourd'hui en référence
impossible encore de savoir si l'été
2006 atteindra les sinistres bilan d'il
ya trois ans mais 2003 ne sera plus à
l'avenir une année exceptionnelle selon
les climatologues nos modèles projette
que un été sur deux sera du type de 2003
à partir de 2005 en a moins de ralentir
l'activité de l'homme responsable du
réchauffement réduire les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre pour le moment
c'est le seul espoir de calmer le climat
et puis comme prévu depuis hier soir les
orages ont éclaté sur l'ouest et dans le
nord images ici de la région de douai
dans le nord
ces orages ont été d'autant plus violent
qu'il avait fait très chaud il y a une
âme une mini-tornade météo france a
enregistré sur place une centaine
d'impacts de foudre il n'y a eu
heureusement que des dégâts matériels
pour fuir la chaleur certains ont choisi
de passer leurs vacances en altitude où
les nuits apporte une fraîcheur
appréciable un petit 15 degrés voici ce
reportage à loudenvielle dans les
hautes-pyrénées muriel la saga olivier
compte il y à ici comme un petit goût de
fraîcheur printanière en un clin d'oeil
c'est comme un souffle d'air qui
rejoignent au pied des montagnes l'herbe
s'est gorgée d'eau grâce aux orages des
derniers jours ces vacanciers
l'attendait avec impatience
non monsieur région parisienne où il
fait très chaud là où il ya du béton et
ça chauffe et dans les mois pour vous
ici c'est un petit bonheur on a en
altitude il ya plus d'air donc c'est
vrai que c'est bien on s'en rend pas
compte qu'il n'ya pas foule mais même un
bon mètre d'altitude
le thermomètre affiche est aujourd'hui
30 degrés sauf qu'ici on ne parle pas de
canicule
car le soir venu c'est une toute autre
histoire marquent les nuits se passe
comment normalement on dort il n'ya pas
40 degrés à l'ombre quoi et c'est bien
pour cette raison que mélanie amène
chaque année ses enfants à la montagne
les enfants n'avaient pas s'endormir des
fois jusqu'à 10h30 11h le soir parce
qu'il faisait trop chaud il fallait
vraiment rafraîchir par tous les moyens
possibles et puis la selref vis couche
tout de suite les fenêtres sont ouvertes
toute la nuit et yappa loustics en plus
c'est génial et le virus gagne au fur et
à mesure que le mercure grimpe tout
dernièrement que des personnes de tous
ceux qui avaient trop très chaud qui
nous ont dit on vous appelle pour venir
se mettre au frais ou pourrait venir
passer deux jours le week-end prochain
est-ce que vous avez des disponibilités
et on a eu le plaisir de les accueillir
dans la vallée au vu des prévisions de
météo france
il pourrait bien être de plus en plus
nombreux à se réfugier dans nos belles
montagnes à l'étranger c'est toujours le
proche orient qui dominent l'actualité
de cette journée au neuvième jour de
l'offensive israélienne au liban les
étrangers continuent à évacuer en masse
le pays
selon le quai d'orsay 2500 français ont
déjà fui et le rythme des évacuations
s'accélère les troupes américaines ont
refait leur apparition pour gérer le
retour de leurs ressortissants il ya
soudain farber
23 ans après leur départ de beyrouth les
marines américains débarquent leur
mission récupérer leurs ressortissants
sur cette plage de dubaï et à 10 km de
la capitale ces passagers ont pour la
plupart la double nationalité
en quelques rotations mille personnes
sont prises en charge à bord de ce
transporteur de troupes lui ss nashville
bienvenue dit la pancarte
c'est la fin du cauchemar
c'était l'horreur on est très heureux
d'être arrivé ici sain et sauf mais on
pense beaucoup à nos familles à nos
proches qui sont des citoyens libanais
mais certains américains sont restés à
quai coincé derrière les grilles fermées
du port scènes de panique de fuite en
avant tout tenter pour arriver au bateau
il faut rentrer chez vous maintenant je
suis sur une liste de l'ambassade
américaine je peux partir d'ici je ne
sais pas ce qui est arrivé à mes enfants
et mon mari au large de tir un navire
chypriote attend une toute première
vague d'évacuation
les casques bleus de la finul des
français organise le rapatriement de 400
compatriote ans ils sont conduits vers
le port de cette ville particulièrement
visé par les bombes
les routes étaient mitraillés par mer ou
par les airs les opérations françaises
de secours se multiplient 2500 personnes
ont pu être rapatriés ils quittent leur
pays avec un mélange de tristesse et de
dégoût
on a l'impression que c'est un terrain
de foot pour tout le monde trinque ces
problèmes sont tout sauf qu'une réaction
de la communauté internationale
pour le moment les militaires étrangers
jouent uniquement un rôle humanitaire
depuis neuf jours l'offensive
israélienne a fait au moins 300 27 morts
au liban et aujourd'hui encore
l'aviation a poursuivi ses actions
actions ciblées ce matin puisqu'elle a
déversé un tapis de bombes sur un bon
coeur du hezbollah au sud de beyrouth
un site censé être occupé par des hauts
responsables du mouvement chiite
libanais les tirs ont touché aujourd'hui
le village chrétien de khiam dans le
nord du pays vous envoyer des images
l'offensive israélienne a déjà causé des
dégâts évalués à plusieurs milliards de
dollars
destruction de ponts de routes de
canalisations centrales électriques
endommagés et face à cette situation
philippe douste-blazy annoncé son départ
ce soit pour le liban et israël
le premier vol france et transportant de
l'aide humanitaire a quitté paris ce
matin direction chypre à son bord des
médecins du personnel de la croix rouge
des groupes électrogènes et des
médicaments qui permettront de venir en
aide aux 500 milles libanais déplacées à
cause de ces bombardements
certains villages notamment au sud du
liban se retrouve totalement isolés à
cause de ces bombardements
nos envoyés spéciaux jacques cardoze et
romain poteau qui ont fait la route
entre beyrouth et la grande ville de
navarre pied une ville considérée comme
un des chefs du hezbollah et qui a donc
été particulièrement visé par les
frappes d'israël pour se rendre dans le
sud du pays bombardé il faut éviter les
grands axes les ponts cible quotidienne
de l'aviation israélienne sont presque
tous détruits les autoroutes coupé au
loin on aperçoit la fumée qui se dégage
de la principale centrale électrique de
la région
les bombardements ont poussé les
habitants à partir cinq mille vivent ta
gym alliés aujourd'hui il n'en reste que
ils ont bombardé trois fois ils ont
lâché 12 bombes rien que cette nuit
maintenant on n'a même plus tôt
pourquoi parce que non mais en sont là
si on va partir en fanfare cette affaire
on peut parvenir
c'est pour cela ces jours ci lorsque les
curé de l'église regarde vers le ciel
ses leçons de l'aviation israélienne
qu'ils entendent en approchant de
nabatiyé on comprend mieux une usine a
été rasée au milieu des décombres
un employé vient récupérer ce qui peut
l'être les registres de l'entreprise ici
plus question de drapeaux blancs ce sont
les jaunes du hezbollah qui flottent au
vent
quelques affiches à la gloire de la
milice chiite une ambiance de chaos
pas de doute nous arrivons à nabatiyé
deux missiles ont ravagé tout ce
quartier
quinze victimes que les habitants du
secourir eux-mêmes ailleurs sur les
poutres les passants comme la levée ce
sont les débris c'était il ya vraiment
par élan parmi eux d'humanitaire ils
viennent pas ici ils n'arrivent pas à
venir parce que c'est dur bombardement
de tous les camions qui passent chacun
encore ça craint un à batié il n'y a ni
électricité ni eau courante et c'est la
population elle même qui se charge de
réparer entre deux bombardements
la ville a payé un lourd tribut parce
qu'elle est réputée pour abriter et
combattants du hezbollah atmosphère
tendue dans le quartier du hezbollah à
beyrouth des rues désertées mais
surveillé de près par la milice
libanaise
gilles mariné et jean francois monier si
souvent dû depuis les bombardements à
sanaa passer sa famille hors de beyrouth
aujourd'hui il revient dans son quartier
à vendre quelques affaires dans
l'appartement quand ce pont était mon
permis je venais juste passé c'était à 3
heures du matin c'est la zone contrôlée
par le hezbollah une frontière dans
beyrouth à partir de là les rues sont
vides mais la milice veille et la caméra
n'est pas la bière
hassan peut repartir dans cette rue une
épicerie restée ouverte
le discours est sans équivoque hassan
nasrallah notre maître nous a appris à
résister jusqu'aux dents ils nous
bombardent encore on reste là on s'en
fiche n'ont pas encore utilisé les
missiles pouvant atteindre tel-aviv en a
pas encore été très méchant ça va venir
le conducteur de la voiture a cité le
nom d'allah et celui de nasrallah le
chef du hezbollah
l'homme qu'israël veut abattre son
effigie est omniprésente
hassan parvient enfin à son immeuble il
veut nous faire visiter son appartement
rencontre avec un voisin qui s'en va
alors est-ce que ça va la famille ça va
on est dans un abri juste à côté il ya
plus personne dans l'immeuble
cet homme et sa famille nombreuse n'ont
pas eu les moyens de partie on a à peine
de quoi survivre de quoi acheter nos
aliments heureusement que les gens du
hezbollah nous aident le voisin repart
vers un abri souterrain que nous ne
pourrons pas visité la milice interrompt
le reportage
cette fois il faut partir ça cent mille
personnes dont beaucoup de sympathisants
du hezbollah vivaient dans ces quartiers
une ville dans la ville
devenu la cible des obus israéliens
malgré la résistance inattendue du
hezbollah malgré la mort aujourd'hui de
quatre soldats
la population israélienne fait corps
derrière son armée et son gouvernement à
la télévision dans les journaux dans la
rue l'heure est à la cohésion nationale
reportage charles enderlin moss jaermann
l'armée israélienne a fini par utiliser
les grands moyens pour conquérir cette
position dure et ce but là
à quelques centaines de mètres de la
frontière car les combattants chiites
opposent une résistance acharnée et
infligent des pertes
osys règne quatre soldats ont été tués
au combat et six blessés aujourd'hui les
échanges de tirs se poursuivent dans
tout le secteur
la destruction des blockhaus et des
tranchées de fès bola au sud-liban
s'annonce difficile
les pertes augmentent le pays se
mobilisent sans grincer des dents les
réservistes revêtent l'uniforme pour une
période indéterminée rappelé d'urgence
ces réservistes étaient il ya seulement
24 heures les employés des banques des
chefs d'entreprise des étudiants
le ton en israël est au patriotisme même
dans le centre du pays où la vie est on
ne peut plus normal mon mari est alarmé
et il se trouve dans le nord
et c'est une situation très difficile
pour nous mais nous devons arrêter tous
et terrorisé bien peu prennent au
sérieux les risques d'atteinte de
missiles sur tel aviv
il n'ya pas de nation plus forte que
nous tout autre peuple aurait plongé
dans la déprime
dans une telle situation face à ce
conflit qui risque de durer
la société israélienne a retrouvé
presque par réflexe tous ses points de
repère des tankers
dans ce contexte la diplomatie a tenté
de reprendre le dessus aujourd'hui kofi
annan a lancé un appel au cessez-le-feu
une trêve pour permettre le stopper ces
crises l'eau et mu vous savez qui veut
mettre en place au sud lui dans une
force de stabilisation et parmi les
réactions à noter celle du prince
héritier d'arabie saoudite arrivé hier à
paris il a dénoncé les agissements
d'israël au liban il a lui aussi rappelé
qu'il était favorable à la mise en place
une force de stabilisation
et puis la croix rouge lance un appel
aux dons d'elle maintenant vous pouvez
les adresser à l'adresse qui s'affiche
sur votre écran
en belgique la justice a décidé de
prolonger la détention préventive de
l'assassin présumé des petites tasty et
nathalie adélaïde houde a été entendu
par le juge d'instruction
malgré les éléments qui l'acclament il
continue à clamer son innocence amaury
guibert samu est une est toujours le
même visage fermé et impassible abdallah
ait oud le principal suspect dans la
sphère doit pourtant faire face à des
éléments de plus en plus accablant et au
fil des interrogatoires ses explications
sont de plus en plus confuse ce matin à
l'audience qui devait statuer sur son
maintien en détention son avocat n'a pas
plaidé la remise en liberté
la position de son client qui nie tout
en bloc lui paraît difficile à tenir
je suis surpris effectivement qu'il
n'ait pas encore changé d'avis alors
qu'il existe de plus en plus les
éléments matériels qui pourraient le
confondent ou en tout cas lui faire le
faire douter effectivement que sa
position soit nécessairement l'abn c'est
après la découverte des corps de
nathalie 11 ans et stacy sept ans que l'
enquête s'est accéléré pas de traces adn
exploitables car les victimes ont reposé
trop longtemps dans l'eau mais la police
scientifique pratiques d'autres analyses
elle retrouve ainsi le même type de
fibres sur les vêtements des fillettes
et ceux du suspect celui ci aurait donc
été en contact avec elle le soir des
faits en fin de matinée les enquêteurs
ont interrogé une nouvelle fois abdallah
ait oud hors de question pour eux de
relâcher la pression les ont la
conviction que la sphère sera bientôt
résolu une conviction forgée par la
qualité du travail de police
scientifique réalisée juste ici en
france fernand blanc est sorti de prison
aujourd'hui en 2002 cet automobiliste de
84 ans avait tué cinq pompiers de loriol
dans la drôme condamné à cinq ans de
prison il a obtenu d'être placé sous
surveillance électronique
il a l'obligation de rester à son
domicile quasiment chaque jour les
douaniers d'orly saisissent du corail
dans les colis postaux en provenance des
antilles et de la guyane
le corail menacées d'extinction et
protégée par la convention de washington
il est donc interdit de le sortir de son
milieu naturel sophie rodier tice et
tristan le bras centre de tri postal
d'orly ce colis vient d'arriver des
antilles à l'intérieur du corail
voilà c'est bien dissimulé a quand même
la preuve que paulette les douaniers en
saisissent presque tous les jours
pendant l'été des souvenirs de vacances
ramasser illégalement sur les plages ou
arrachées directement sur la barrière de
corail
les touristes les envoient par la poste
vers la métropole
j'en ramène et censure puis après que la
marche a été celui de douala menacées
d'extinction les coraux sont protégés
par la convention de washington
il est donc strictement interdit d'en
ramasser vivant ou mort
cette espèce met des années à se
reconstituer parfois elle ne réapparaît
jamais malgré les avertissements les
douaniers continue d'en trouver dans les
colis des touristes 200 pièces ont été
saisies depuis le début de l'année à
horgues si tous les gens qui savent que
c'est interdit ni n'en prennent plus le
marché se tarit lui même donc on a
atteint nos deux buts en fait
en théorie les touristes encourt une
amende mais dans les faits les autorités
se contentent de saisir la marchandise
les coraux confisqués sont confiés à des
musées aujourd'hui plus de 600 personnes
s'étaient rassemblées devant le tribunal
de saint-gaudens en haute-garonne pour
soutenir dix éleveurs poursuivi par la
justice en avril dernier avait
occasionné des dégâts lors d'une
manifestation contre la réintroduction
de l'ours
le procureur a requis jusqu'à quatre
mois de prison avec sursis à grands
coups d'annoncés de publicité dans les
journaux l'état continue à vendre une
partie de son patrimoine immobilier
l'état qui espère bien récupérer
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
cette année
des hôtels particuliers des immeubles de
standing qui n'auront pas de mal à
trouver des acquéreurs
françois baudot n'est bernie mériaux ce
petit écrin de nature est niché au coeur
de l'un des quartiers les plus prisés de
la capitale
un hôtel particulier des années 20 qui
pendant quelques mois encore abritera
les fonctionnaires de la direction de
l'aménagement du territoire un chef
d'oeuvre d'architecturé de 90 pièces sur
2500 mètres carrés isabelle adjani avait
gravi cet escalier dans le film camille
claudel
mais ce bijou du patrimoine de l'état
n'est pas fonctionnel comme des
centaines d'autres immeubles
il sera vendu est bon se séparer de
bâtiments comme celui ci l'état emploie
les grands moyens site internet pleines
pages dans les journaux on y trouve tous
les détails sauf les prix de vente
nous les avons demandé un spécialiste de
l'immobilier et sur cette page il ya
cinq immeubles deux hôtels particuliers
qui valent entre 20 et 25 millions
d'euros probablement rue ça ne me dit
qu'aucun du 7e arrondissement
probablement le même tranche de valeur
25 millions d'euros et enfin rue
d'astorg mieux plein huitième entre 70
et 80 millions d'euros
au total près de 120 millions d'euros
pour cette seule publicité une somme
impressionnante mais ne rêvons pas elles
ne représentent que 0 0 1 % de la dette
de l'état
la chaleur a marqué l'ouverture de la
5ème édition de paris plages on attend 4
millions de visiteurs pendant un mois la
capitale va prendre des airs de station
balnéaire avec une température
supérieure à 30 degrés les familles
étaient nombreuses à venir profiter des
brumisateurs points d'eau et piscine
anne-sophie chaumié le comte mathieu
bien dès l'exercice exige un zeste de
souplesse à chacun sa méthode
mais j'aime plagistes l'urbain cherche
avant tout à s'hydrater
idéal voilà le contrat pêcher avec tous
les moyens du bord paris-plages re des
plissés transat la chaleur et toof la
capitale depuis plusieurs jours
cette pause sur la croisette parisienne
était très attendu quand on vient ville
où est le fond reste à la maison c'est
les étouffant ici on est bien quand même
si on est au devant de la scène et
saint-céré grand classique la forêt des
brumisateurs a toujours autant de succès
les touristes semblent apprécier
je trouve ça vraiment formidable ce
qu'ils ont fait et je me demande
pourquoi il va pendant tout l'été
un mois c'est déjà bien doivent se dire
certains déjà loin très loin des tracas
de la vie
mais attention le coup de chaud peut
vite arriver
la croix-rouge circulent en permanence
sur les quais histoire de rappeler
quelques règles
de l'autre côté de la scène certains ont
trouvé la solution
plongée dans la toute nouvelle piscine
juste en face des fenêtres de bercy les
finances justement 10 euros pour 3
heures une exception à paris-plage
toutes les autres attractions sont
gratuites
cette image de l'éruption du piton de la
fournaise à la réunion la préfecture a
décidé d'interdire l'accès au site du
volcan
l'activité se situe au niveau du cratère
bory au sommet du volcan
le piton de la fournaise est l'un des
plus actifs au monde
et puis on termine comme prévu par un
hommage à gérard oury hommage de la rue
de tous ceux qui a apprécié ses comédies
avec les plus grands acteurs bourvil de
funès ou belmondo des morceaux
d'anthologie qui reste dans toutes les
mémoires
olivier les noda à la location les
oliviers à saint tropez
gérard oury c'était un ce matin dans
cette vie là un lieu d'une grande
douceur un endroit qu'il aimait a
souligné danièle thompson la fille du
réalisateur le port d'attache d'un homme
qui laisse le souvenir d'un grand éclat
de rire en cinémascope
on s'installait sur le canapé avec mes
mes parents mes grands parents surtout
ils ont partagé ça tous ensemble comme
une sorte de ses pas de jubilation
intergénérationnel on zappe parle
contient gérard oury qui passe à la télé
mais ses partenaires à dix le bal est
apprise dans lui avec un montant très
drôle
avec l'oiseau en de funès inité
ce perroquet en verre de coca crédit au
bizz'art club
ah bah oui c'est le mot vous êtes juste
moi par exemple je suis juif
juif
commence alors entre jed juive
salomon je suis j'ai vécu ma vie à
travers lui son coup d'essai ce fut un
coup de maître le corniaud 1964 pendant
plus de 40 ans gérard oury réalisa un
bien joli voyage ça compte dans la vie
la dame
un voyage de toute une vie dans le monde
du rire millions voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci à vous de l'avoir subie
tout de suite la météo suivi du point
route vingt cinq ans dancing show
présenté par anthony kavanagh et je me
retrouve avec plaisir à 23h30 pour une
immersion totale au coeur d'une clinique
de chirurgie esthétique
à tout à l'heure excellente soirée sur
france 2